the biden white house facing fresh
accusations of colluding with big tech
to censor americans a new lawsuit filed
by two republican attorneys general is
pushing for the release of more emails
between top biden officials and big tech
titans after getting their hands on docs
that shed a light on their cozy
relationship they say the evidence is
appalling
we know it's at the highest levels of
government but we don't know exactly how
high and how wide this goes because the
department of justice is objecting to uh
discovery to the folks in the white
house and they're claiming uh executive
privilege which is nonsense because
we're not even asking for internal
communications we're asking for
communications with these third parties
this ought to shock every american
regardless of your political stripe that
the government is actually censoring and
silencing americans
okay so what we've got is what we've
always suspected kaylee and that is that
the white house the biden administration
is colluding with big tech facebook and
twitter and basically telling them what
they should suppress and not suppress
the question is does the white house
have that right no of course they don't
and in fact it's likely illegal what
they're doing because you can't suppress
the first amendment speech of a citizen
when you are the united states federal
government even via a subsidiary um that
disinformation board that didn't happen
appears to have happened in practice
when you have 45 federal officials who
engaged in this according to the
attorneys general 11 agencies that's a
big operation uh we knew this jinsocki
told us on july 15th that flagging
problematic facebook posts and the
spread of disinformation was a priority
so they admitted this out loud but what
is striking to me because we knew this
was happening at the federal government
is the third parties who willingly
engage when you had a facebook official
email the surgeon general and say i know
our team's met today to better
understand the scope of what the white
house expects from us remember that guy
brian stelter it reminds me of when he
said to jen saki how can we be better
this is social media what do you expect
of us big media how can we be better
sensing a trend it is essentially
private sector partnering with the
democrat party that is brian
ryan
i know you do all gut fell you know joey
one of the things that is so disturbing
is that jen sackey as kelly just said
openly admitted flagging what they
considered problematic posts which is
basically the biden administration being
a censorship enterprise a violation as
kaylee says of the first amendment
where do they get off doing this they
don't have much objectivity to them they
they're not trying to hide it because
they believe it's righteous it's holy
it's the truth right in their minds we
didn't get to decide what was or wasn't
good for our bodies they did we so so
they would have flagged uh you know a
post about mass early on if they had had
this type of uh coordination going early
on maybe during the if they've been in
charge for the first year of covet they
would have they would have flag post
that said you know mask only work if
you're trying not to spread it but it
doesn't really help you catching it and
then six months later fauci comes out
and says something to that effect they
they would have been all stepping all
over themselves had they had this
capability and been in the white house
for the first year of this pandemic and
so as things change as new information
comes out they have to accept that some
of the guidance early on even if it was
well intended was ill-advised and and to
think that they were squashing people
who went out and did their own research
found their own answers and just put it
out there and to say you didn't have you
don't have the right to do that in a
country with the first amendment but
they're not going to try to hide it
because they don't care because they
think they're righteous in doing this
they believe in their power more than
our rights you know the the
disinformation board that they they
floated and then you know they saw that
america wasn't going to accept it is
really in effect
although they don't have it out there
openly with what's her name singing mary
poppins uh but they basically have a
disinformation board do you think that's
constitutional jessica
i'm not sure the courts i guess will
play it out if it ever gets taken there
i'm i'm not a lawyer and i don't want to
pretend to be one but you know about the
first amendment i'm yes i do know about
the first amendment and i know that
there are concerns that a company would
take to make sure that they are
protecting people or on there especially
when it comes to something like medical
information i will say joey that
actually the reality was according to
facebook that the trump administration
was coordinating with them when covet
first started so this was something that
wasn't just a
well maybe it didn't cross your desk
maybe no
that was my desk okay well it was there
was a chiron of it earlier that facebook
says
no
actually but
anyway i want to say so i was pregnant
during the pandemic and one of the main
pieces of disinformation that was going
around was that if you got vaccinated
while you were pregnant that you were
had higher likelihood of miscarrying
that's obviously something that's
incredibly scary and i ended up getting
vaccinated while i was pregnant my
doctor assured me that it was fine
but
making sure that information like that
is not getting out there is a worthy
cause and i'm not for
censorship i am for careful
looking at these kinds of things because
there are people who are getting bad
information over social media and you
know whether it's that they would have
cared about hunter biden's laptop i care
about that a lot less than the people
who are getting bad information about
medicines that could help save their
lives or could pass immunity on to their
growing babies which is what happened my
daughter was born with antibodies
because i got vaccinated while i was
pregnant greg how about the fact that
some of the stuff that they were telling
us during the pandemic turned out to be
absolutely not supported not true not
accurate and all of a sudden they want
to say to us well we still be we still
need to be in charge of what you do and
don't do shouldn't it be between you and
your doctor and if anyone goes to the
internet to figure this stuff out well
that's that's a risk that they take i
think that's uh the the the big point is
is that everybody in a way deserves a
mulligan when you have a pandemic once
every 100 years there's going to be
people that are going to be initially be
right and then wrong and then that's
going to change i am pro
disinformation because one man's
disinformation is another person's fact
right a sensor never says they're a
censor they just say they're concerned
about your health and so they use
medical information now as kind of the
as their weaponry to uh start curtailing
information so disinformation has now
become the new hate speech right and and
they use health as a shield almost like
they how they make everything now is a
health problem so now like uh language
can be a health problem the language
that you use could be hurtful and that
is a health problem they could say that
uh inequality or
lack of equity is a health problem so
you have to be very careful that they're
playing this game it's all about
controlling the megaphone we've learned
that the left sees social media as an
extension of media a platform where they
can manipulate the spigot turn on the
propaganda turn it off and they always
feel like they're entitled to it because
going back to the a block
they see that the other side is evil and
therefore should not have the same
rights they do because everything that
i'm going to say is obviously going to
be disinformation right you know there
are people that disagree with you
jessica about the trial a lot of people
did not get back vaccinated and you
can't argue and they and they'll be very
polite to you about it you got you can't
say like you know what you shouldn't
have got that information the solution
to misinformation is always more
information not less yeah i want to say
and i think that this is true of a lot
of kind of hot topic political debates
especially when you talk about an issue
like abortion i've always felt this way
no one is right or wrong necessarily
it's about what legal legalities are and
protections are i i never told a woman
you got to get vaccinated right now that
is your body your choice about that
absolutely but i don't think that bad
information should be allowed to
circulate about miscarriages that were
not happening i don't know how you i
don't know how you how do you police
that i mean really how do you police
that bad information i get it if
somebody says you know
it's perfectly legal to set fire to
things that's bad information maybe you
can get charged for telling a child he
can light a fire
okay that's a crime that is objective as
a society we have said these laws have
to be followed you violate them then you
violated the social contract there's a
part of the story that's buried though
because social media companies now are
almost in this place we're like oh but
it was the fbi it was the administration
social media companies are the ones that
created this bubble that we live in that
we only get a certain type of
information because they believe that's
what we want and it keeps us addicted to
opening this phone and so they they have
to acknowledge their own sins in this
before they can punt it over to any
administration on censoring they are
censoring us before the administration
even has a chance to yeah
so up next america's never-ending travel
nightmare is about to ruin your labor
day and the biden administration is
totally clueless on how to fix it hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now